- [Man] The American nation can not,
must now, and will not,
from empty establishment,
form another communist government.
- This is called a Cavendish banana.
It's the most common banana on earth.
It's probably the one that
you have in your kitchen right now.
It's definitely the one you
see in the grocery store.
This banana was created in a
fancy looking house in England.
Yes, created and yes, in England.
Kind of weird, bananas
aren't from England.
They're originally from
Asia and there are thousands
of different kinds of bananas.
So how did this banana,
the Cavendish that was created in England
become the banana that you eat today?
Well, the answer to that is not so simple.
You have to understand the
story of bananas, which yes,
is something we're diving into today.
It's a story filled with
predatory corporations
and geopolitics and American
imperialism and disease,
and really some amazing marketing.
It explains how
corporations can grow so big
that they begin to act like
governments, like dictators.
And it explains why this
banana, the Cavendish,
the one you know and love,
might not exist soon.
- [Woman] The world's most popular banana
may be on the verge of extinction.
Oh, and while I was diving deep into this,
I discovered that there's a
better tasting banana out there.
One that isn't supposed to exist anymore,
but I got my hands on some
and yes, they're better.
So buckle up.
This is the F'd up history of bananas.
We're pausing this story really
quick because I just need to
thank the sponsor of today's
video, which is stamps.com,
a service that I have used
for now several years,
long before they came to sponsor a video.
So it's kind of cool.
A few years ago, I became independent,
which meant I had to start
running my own business.
I quickly realized that running a business
means shipping things a lot.
I was shipping hard drives with footage.
I was shipping gear and lenses.
I was going to the post office a bunch,
which is kind of my nightmare.
So I Googled like what's the best way
to not go to the post office
and stamps.com came up,
stamps.com is all of the things
that the post office does,
but in your office or house.
I can ship packages and
letters for less cost
from the comfort of this studio.
In fact, right behind me is
my whole stamps.com set up,
got a fancy scale.
So I literally put the
package on this scale.
It tells me how much it is.
It plugs into my computer
and I type in the address
of where I'm sending it.
And it spits out a shipping
label that I then print
with my label printer and
I put it on the package.
And then I put it at my front door
and it gets taken away by the mail person.
It's the easiest thing in the world.
And I'm very grateful
that I discovered it,
stamps.com is saving lots of
businesses time and money.
It has certainly saved me
a lot of time and money,
which is why I'm really grateful
that they're supporting this channel
and sponsoring today's video.
You can get four weeks of this for free
if you want to just try it out.
There's a link in my description,
stamps.com/johnnyharris.
If you sign up, you'll
get this free trial,
plus some free postage
and a digital scale.
You'll get one of those scales,
which is incredibly helpful.
There's no long-term
commitment or contracts.
Just go to stamps.com/johnnyharris
to start your trial,
get a free scale and some postage
and never have to go to
the post office again.
So bananas are from Southeast
Asia, but like 400 years ago,
Europeans were taking over the world
and the Portuguese brought
bananas over to the Americas.
A few hundred years later,
an American sailor was in Jamaica
and he found this funny
looking exotic yellow fruit
and money started flashing in his eyes.
He started selling bananas to Americans
who quickly loved this new fruit.
Bananas were trending.
People were talking about it.
So then fast forward to
nearly the end of the 1800s.
And you have the World's Fair,
where all the people show up
and show off their new technology.
At the fair you've got this guy,
Alexander Graham bell,
who's showing up with his
cute little new invention
that's about to change the world.
But another crowd favorite
at the expo was the banana.
Yes, bananas were equally as impressive
as the telephone at the World's Fair.
The banana business started
booming in the United States.
Much of these bananas flowing
in from New York City.
The port there was dubbed
Banana Docks for a while
because of so much fruit import.
So now you have all these
Americans eating the sweet,
creamy, delicious fruit,
and throwing the slippery
peels onto the street.
It got so bad that the police
commissioner at the time,
oh God, I can't get away from this guy.
Teddy Roosevelt once again.
I swear I get into any story,
I like to start to research it.
And it's like, yeah.
And then there's an American imperialism.
And Teddy Roosevelt shows up.
Anyway, so Teddy Roosevelt,
the police commissioner starts
putting a fine on people for
throwing their banana
peels on the sidewalk.
Like this isn't just
like a silly, fake joke.
It's like, this is a real thing.
People slipped on banana peels.
- Patrick, banana peel!
- What did you say? (screams)
- And you could go to jail
for it. I mean, look at this.
There's this New York Times article
documenting Teddy Roosevelt,
the police commissioner,
speaking to a room of police
captains, explaining quote,
the bad habits of banana
skins and dwelling
particularly on its tendency
to toss people into the air
and bring them down with terrific force
on the hard pavement.
This was a real issue.
Banana Docks, Teddy Roosevelt,
slippery banana peels,
silly newspaper articles
from the late 1800s.
This isn't the story here.
We're just getting started.
This is banana's innocent phase.
It's about to heat up.
Let's see how bananas
turned from this to this.
(upbeat music)
The banana business
people in the US realized
it was time to ramp up to
meet all of this new demand.
But instead of just importing
more bananas from say
Jamaica or other countries
in the Caribbean,
the banana companies realized
that they needed to
control the supply chain.
Let me explain what I mean by second,
by looking at this banana.
Bananas are fragile. They're soft.
They spoil in like a week,
but this one's like
moments away from spoiling.
Look at those spots.
To get this thing from
somewhere close to the equator
all the way to New York City
and then into someone's market
and then into somebody's home
all without it being crushed
and without it spoiling is a fragile,
quick, expensive process.
And the only way to do it
profitably is to do a lot of it.
A lot of bananas.
(upbeat music)
And the only way to do a lot of bananas
is to control the supply chain.
So it's like 1900 at this point,
there's a banana gold rush happening.
And there's a bunch of
companies trying to figure out
how to control the supply chain.
And then they decided to sort
of merge together and become
this one super company called
the United Fruit Company.
And their plan for combining was to
control everything,
control the supply chain.
They turned their attention
completely to Central America
where they know bananas
could grow abundantly,
and where, oh, look at this.
The US is thinking about
making a little canal that cuts
through this little narrow strip of land.
So the United Fruit Company is like,
that's kind of a nice perk for the region.
If anything goes wrong,
the US could have our backs.
Foreshadowing.
Am I foreshadowing? I'm foreshadowing.
So yeah, United Fruit Company is like,
this region, central America ,
looks like a great neighborhood
to control the supply chain.
They wanted to control
the people who worked
on the farm by owning
their basic survival needs.
They wanted to control
the houses they lived in
and the stores they shopped
in and what they could buy.
They wanted to control the
transportation by building
railways so that they could quickly ship
their product onto ports.
They wanted to control the
boats and the waterways so that
they could get all of these
bananas from Central America
to the US before they spoiled.
They started with Guatemala,
pouring tons of investment into
controlling every inch
of their supply chain.
Soon, they were the largest
company in Guatemala.
They owned a fifth of the
farmable land in the country.
They owned all of the railways and
all of the radio stations
and radio infrastructure.
And by 1901,
the government of Guatemala
actually hired the
United Fruit Company to manage
the country's postal service.
What?
United Fruit was starting to
look a lot like a government.
And the result was a lot of
happy banana eating Americans.
So they kept going.
They kept expanding their
operations across Central America.
So now with all of this
beautiful infrastructure
and trains and land,
the next strategy for making
bananas even more profitable
was, you guessed it, paying
the workers next to nothing.
And paying them not with real money.
(upbeat music)
A lot of the times United Fruit
paid their workers in vouchers.
These vouchers could only be used
in designated United Fruit commissaries.
So they're not actually
making real money here.
So wait, now the United fruit
Company has its own currency?
Oh, and they also had like a private Navy,
93 boats called the Great White Fleet.
Then eventually they
started using these boats
to transport people on cruises.
These boats were even
used during World War II.
United Fruit started to look
like a literal government.
They had their hands in
everything so much so
that they earned their
self the nickname El Pulpo,
which means the octopus in Spanish,
meaning they had their
tentacles in everything
all over Central America, the
land, the crops, the people,
the infrastructure, and soon
enough government agencies.
Soon these countries
became so dominated by
and reliant on the United Fruit Company
that they were no longer run
by the people or the governments.
They were run by American banana companies
who had all the power and
leverage in the world.
This led to the nickname Banana Republic,
which is a politically unstable
country whose society is
exploited for profit
for one single product,
in this case bananas.
And probably not the best
sort of thing to name
your clothing store after,
but just a thought, but
like who made that decision?
United Fruit and other banana companies
continued to grow and
control Central America.
Eventually people got tired of this.
In 1911, Honduras was like,
all right, we're done,
banana companies.
We're going to take back our land.
We can take it from here.
These are our plantations.
You've gone too far. Banana
companies didn't like this.
So they organized a private
army to help overthrow the
government so that they
could put in a president
that they liked who would allow them
to keep doing exactly what they
were doing and also give them a tax break.
So yeah,
banana companies are now
overthrowing governments.
Jeez.
This kept happening.
Anytime there was political
dissent or the governments
of these countries started
to step up and say no,
the banana companies would intervene,
and guess who had their back?
The US military, and yes,
we're back to Teddy Roosevelt.
Teddy Roosevelt.
What a guy.
Here's Teddy stomping around the
Caribbean with his big stick,
making sure that American
military and business interests
are protected, in Honduras alone,
the US invaded seven
times in the early 1900s,
all in the name of protecting
these banana companies
and other US interests
from having to face these pesky locals
who were so audacious as to
want to run their own country.
How dare they?
If you remember that at this time,
the US was starting to get
really comfortable with empire
behavior and central America
was at the top of the priority list.
The banana companies knew this,
which allowed them to feel emboldened,
to just sort of do whatever
they wanted in the region.
But this is sort of child's play.
It started to get a
lot worse in the 1920s.
(upbeat music)
There was a situation in
Colombia where a bunch of workers
for the United Fruit Company
decided to stop working
and protest their working conditions.
They were asking for a few
things like, I don't know,
working six days a week instead of seven,
or getting paid real money.
The United Fruit Company
refuses to negotiate with them.
And instead goes to the
US and says, hey, USA,
we've got these really
annoying workers who are
trying to unionize and
trying to get paid and stuff.
And it actually smells
a lot like communism.
And the US is like, wait, what, communism?
Tell me more.
So then the US threatens to invade
with their Marines and squash this strike
if the Colombian military
doesn't do something first.
Reminder that we're not talking about
some big political
revolution or rebellion.
We're talking about a few
workers in a banana plantation
protesting for more humane conditions.
And yet this was a priority
for the US government
to put pressure on Colombia
to fix the situation.
Of course, Columbia didn't
want to make the US angry.
So they responded and
sent in their own troops
to go put down this workers' strike.
And they were ordered to quote,
spare no ammunition.
So on December 5th, 1928,
these protesters are in the town square
in this town in Columbia.
And the Colombian army
shows up and massacres them.
Men, women, and children were
killed by their own military
all because an American banana company
didn't want to pay them a decent wage.
I mean, this is madness.
It is madness to think that
these large geopolitical forces
were coming to bear over
a banana plantation.
This event is called the Banana Massacre.
This didn't stop in 1928,
fast forward to Guatemala in the 1950s.
At this point,
the United Fruit Company, El Pulpo,
is making major profits.
They own almost 50% of the
land in Guatemala tax-free.
But this president, Jacobo Arbenz,
who was democratically elected
is trying to change things.
He wants to take land
that United Fruit owns
but isn't using and redistribute
it to poor Guatemalans.
He's sort of doing like
a Robin Hood thing,
trying to like lift poor
Guatemalans out of poverty.
But of course, United
Fruit didn't like this,
but instead of engaging directly
with the Guatemalan government,
United Fruit goes to the white house
and says those magic
words again, communism.
United Fruit then hired this PR magician
who happened to be Sigmund Freud's nephew.
And he worked with news
agencies to create a bunch
of fake stories that linked Arbenz,
the president of Guatemala to communism,
completely fake news.
And not just like using that word lightly,
like he created a fake
Guatemalan newspaper,
created all these fake reports
and then distributed those
fake newspapers to Congress.
He planted the seeds in their minds
that United Fruit Company
were the good guys
and that Arbenz,
the democratically elected leader,
needed to go because of communism.
It totally worked.
President Eisenhower,
the president of the United
States believed all of this.
And he sent in the CIA to
get Arbenz out of power
to protect the banana people once again.
It's a classic CIA coup, they
go find a bunch of rebels.
They give them money and they train them.
- [Radio Announcer] Rebels rose to oust
Guatemala's red infiltrated government.
- They find a leader who
wants to be the next president
that's friendly to the US
and eventually they start
broadcasting anti-government propaganda,
and they turn Guatemalans
against their government
with all of this fake news and propaganda.
They send the Navy in to
block Guatemalan waters.
They send some bombs onto Guatemala city,
and then they invade.
(dramatic music)
And then with these trained fighters,
they go take over the government,
the Guatemalan army surrenders,
and the leader of the rebels becomes
the new president friendly
to the United States.
And now the banana companies
are happy and they have a guy
in power that is their guy.
It's like they have a playbook on how to
mess with democracies around the world.
And they just sort of
followed the playbook.
They're like, oh, we've done this before.
We're going to do it again
in Iran in a little bit.
This is classic CIA coup, by the way,
this coup was sort of a death blow
to democracy in Guatemala.
It divided and destroyed
the budding civil society
that has not allowed
Guatemala to recover since,
all because these banana companies
wanted to control the supply chain.
These things leave scars, major scars,
major marks on a country, scars
that are still felt today.
Let's switch gears for a
second because all of these
banana coups and banana republics
and massacres is like horrendous.
But during all of this violence
and military invasions and
human rights violations,
all of this meant that
the United Fruit Company
was getting really, really
good at their business.
They were sending too many
bananas to the United States.
There was a ton of bananas supplied,
but demand wasn't rising fast enough.
The average American didn't
totally know how to use bananas.
So the United Fruit Company
creates this amazing marketing campaign.
(upbeat music)
So now they're paying
doctors to write amazing
academic journal articles about bananas.
They cut a deal with
Kellogg's to market the cereal
as something that pairs with bananas,
which is something I still do today.
I cut up my bananas and
I put them in my cereal
because of this campaign.
They targeted moms with small children.
They made recipe books.
They even created a guide on
how to decorate with bananas.
- [TV Broadcaster]
Bananas can to be served
in many different and
many attractive ways.
Blended with fruits, nuts, and gelatin,
they provide high food
value with nourishment.
- But their biggest
success was Miss Chiquita.
♪ I'm Chiquita Banana
and I've come to say ♪
♪ bananas have to ripen
in a certain way. ♪
♪ And when they're flecked with
brown and have a golden hue ♪
♪ Bananas taste the best
and are the best for you. ♪
- The American public fell in love
with this lady and bananas.
They had no idea that these bananas
that were being produced and
shipped and bought with blood,
they just liked how they taste.
But isn't that the case
with a lot of things
that we all consume every day.
But there's one thing that US
imperialism and millions of
dollars of marketing cannot
control, which is disease.
This is the part of the
story that I tell you
that the bananas that were all the rage
during the 1900s are not the bananas
that you're eating today.
(upbeat music)
Part of United Fruit Company's
efforts to control everything
was standardizing the
genetics of the banana,
making them all exactly the same.
Monocultures is what we call that.
The problem with monocultures
is that they are heaven
for a disease because
you don't have to solve
the same puzzle to infect another banana.
If you infect one, you infect them all.
And that's exactly what happened.
Panama disease was a fungus that came in
and destroyed banana plantations.
The banana supply in
the US shrank rapidly.
And there was even a hit song
about the banana shortage.
♪ We have no bananas today ♪
The banana that they had been using,
the one that was getting
really popular in the US
was called the Gros Michel,
or the Big Mike banana,
but it was now completely
getting ravaged by disease.
So these banana companies
are freaking out.
They're like, we are done,
we've built this entire empire
and this disease is going to wipe us out.
So they started to scramble
to find another banana.
It turns out there's like
a thousand types of bananas out there.
There's red ones and
blue ones and teal ones.
I mean, a blue banana.
I feel like I have to eat a blue banana
at some point in my life,
but here's the problem.
Us Americans, we buy our food
kind of with our eyes first.
We're just like, it needs to look good.
And so these companies
realized they couldn't
send a blue banana to the United States.
They needed a banana that
looked similar, yellow,
sweet and seedless so that
they could keep selling to
Americans who hopefully
wouldn't notice the switch.
Enter our friend, the Cavendish banana
♪ God save the precious queen ♪
Like I said at the beginning,
this banana was invented by a
British guy who was tinkering
with banana seeds in this
amazing looking house
in Northern England.
And after years of playing
around with the genetics,
the plant finally flowered
and popped out this big,
beautiful yellow banana.
And so he named it after
the Duke William Cavendish.
So now here's the sad part.
The Gros Michel,
the one that had caught on
that was like the big hit in
America was a way better banana,
is a way better banana.
It is sweeter.
It's more durable and it's
just overall a better banana
compared to the Cavendish.
In fact,
the artificial banana flavor
that we have in our candies,
like Laffy Taffy comes from
the original Gros Michel,
not from the Cavendish,
but the Gros Michel was getting
destroyed by this disease.
And the Cavendish was luckily
resistant to the disease.
So the dictator banana companies
made the switch and hoped
that the people wouldn't care or notice
as long as they looked the same.
And guess what? It totally worked.
They quietly switched out the
banana to the new Cavendish
and people just kept buying bananas.
I mean,
I can't believe that there
is a better banana out there
that I have not tasted.
I wonder if I can get my hands on one.
(upbeat music)
The Gros Michel banana still exists.
It's just a select few people
on this planet still grow it.
And I found a farm that sent me a few.
I'm going to try this thing.
Gros Michel. Let's do this
Beautiful banana. Wow.
I'm obviously primed to like this more
so I don't know if I'm
really liking it more,
but it's definitely a better
banana right now in my mind.
Slightly different color.
It's got this like burgundy vibe going on.
It's sweeter. I like the texture more.
I think this is a better banana.
Too bad this thing got completely
wiped out by a disease.
So let's get up to speed
before we finish the story off,
because the last part of
it is quite interesting
and applies to our modern day.
To summarize,
came to the US, predatory
companies invaded whole countries
to help the US exploit them for bananas
while using amazing
marketing to keep demand up.
And because of this Panama Disease,
they had to switch to the
inferior Cavendish banana.
So where do we go from here?
United fruit eventually
rebranded to Chiquita.
They're still doing
some pretty shady stuff
like paying millions
of dollars to terrorist
death squads and getting sued by workers
who've become sterile
after handling pesticides.
Banana companies will
probably always do this.
Because the other thing that remains
is that bananas are still soft and
spoil quickly and grow in far away places
from where you eat them.
So the entire supply chain
needs to be controlled.
And the other thing that
hasn't changed is that the new
banana is genetically optimized
so that every banana is exactly the same.
So it fits perfectly into these boxes,
into these crates, onto these ships,
into these supermarkets.
But guess what? There's another disease.
The Panama disease,
the one that wiped out the Gros Michel,
it's back and it's mutated,
and it's coming for the Cavendish.
And what's tricky about these
diseases is there's no way to
detect them before they
arrive before it's too late.
It just quietly kills the banana trees
and makes it impossible
to ever grow there again,
you have to burn the entire plantation.
This is already happening
in the Philippines,
which is the second largest
exporter of bananas,
the disease has devastated the
land and the banana economy.
It's making its way through Asia.
But Asia is super far away and it's like,
there's a whole ocean in between.
All our bananas come from
Latin America. Wrong.
In 2019,
it was detected in Colombia.
And in April of this year,
just a few months ago,
the disease was found in
Peru, right next to Ecuador,
which is the largest exports
of bananas that come to the US.
It's coming for your bananas.
So everyone's on high alert and bananas
as we know them might be doomed.
So now we're seeing history
kind of repeat itself.
We're looking at the potential collapse
of a $25 billion industry
and entire economies,
which is like hundreds
of thousands of jobs.
(dramatic music)
To me, the big problem here,
the thing that's repeating
itself is the same problem
of United Fruit Company going
in and trying to control
every angle of their
production to maximize profits.
When we have companies
that feel emboldened
to do whatever it takes
to make the most profit,
you're going to get situations like this,
whether it is banana massacres in Columbia
or a coup in Honduras
or a monoculture that
gets wiped out by disease
time and time again,
we try to engineer our
way out of these problems
and we sometimes do, but
at the end of the day,
nature will catch up with us.
And as long as we ignore the
true cost of these economies,
the cost to people, to
democracies, to ecologies,
we're never actually going
to get rid of these problems.
Thanks for watching.
I'm going to eat a Cavendish now.
See you.